[Musik]
gibt es irgend jemanden der hinter den
kulissen der macht den globalen
kapitalismus kontrolliert einen geheimen
spiel der märkte und weltwirtschaft nach
seiner pfeife tanzen lässt sicher du
hast du regelmäßig von all den
lieblingen der verschwörungstheoretiker
da wären auch zur erde schreibt die
linien in menschengestalt die rothschild
und natürlich george soros und du denkst
natürlich das sind alles spinnereien
aber es gibt tatsächlich ein spieler mit
sehr viel mehr macht als sich all die
verschwörungs heinis vorstellen können
und sicher hat die niemand von den
jemals was von diesem spieler erzählt es
handelt sich um keinen geringeren als
der norwegischen regierung ja
norwegen ist weit mehr als nur ein sehr
reiches land seine regierung beherrscht
große teile der weltwirtschaft denke
jetzt dass ich spinne nun am ende dieses
videos du wirst du sehen dass ich recht
habe
[Applaus]
[Musik]
norwegen ist das einzige land der welt
in dem satanische black metal songs die
charts erobert haben
tja liebe zuschauer solltet ihr jemals
in dieses land reisen und das radio
einschalten werdet ihr vielleicht nicht
taylor swift zu hören bekommen sondern
bands wie hotmail oder lenny meister mit
ihrem hit my
[Musik]
ja ich weiß möglicherweise gehen in
diesem land ziemlich musikalische
merkwürdige dinge vor sich
außerdem ist nur wegen aber eines der
reichsten länder der welt und spielt
wohlstands nächste ich in einer liga mit
ländern wie irland unter schwarz
norwegen verfügt darüber hinaus auch
noch über eine der egalitäre und sozial
ausgewogenen gesellschaftsstrukturen
weltweit das bedeutet dass die
unterschiede zwischen reich und arm
äußerst klein sind der norwegische
sozialstaat ist gewalt die steuern sind
hoch und die lebensqualität für alle
sehr aber das weißt du wahrscheinlich
bereits was ihr wahrscheinlich nicht ist
ist dass norwegens einfluss auf die
internationale wirtschaft viel größer
ist als es scheint ja norwegen ist
strippenzieher der größten
multinationalen konzern
ok ok klickt dieses video jetzt nicht
gleich weg ich weiß was du denkst aber
keine angst dieses video ist keineswegs
in zusammenarbeit mit kollegen standen
es beruht einzig und allein auf sauber
recherchierten und belegbaren fakten
also gut legen wir los
wusstet ihr dass in norwegen weniger als
fünf millionen menschen leben das heißt
weniger als in new york city dennoch
besitzen diese fünf millionen menschen
große beteiligungen an den größten
unternehmen der welt die norwegische
regierung hat nämlich ihren eigenen
hedgefonds und dieser gehört zu den
hauptaktionären viele unternehmen wie
apple facebook und tesla norwegen hat
vielleicht keine großes militär aber es
verfügt über eine enorme monetäre
streitmacht welche in der lage ist die
weltwirtschaft entscheidend zu
beeinflussen und so stellt sich die
frage wie ist norwegen so reich und
mächtig geworden an dieser stelle denkt
ihr alle an das gleiche erdöl
und ja ihr habt damit nicht ganz unrecht
norwegen ist einer der größten
ölproduzenten der welt aber sie sind
ganz anders als all die anderen
ölreichen länder seht ihr dieses bild an
hier seht ihr die skyline von riad der
hauptstadt saudi-arabiens es sieht aus
wie in einem science fiction film ist
wahr
pompöse vollkasko futuristischer
architektur und viele glitzernde lichter
betrachten wir nun dieses bild von
öffnung der hauptstadt moritz muss ich
den unterschied oder also diese politik
ist wissen sie vielleicht bereits das
große ölvorkommen den reichtum nicht
automatisch mit sich bringen tatsächlich
ist die förderung norwegischen rohöls
wir dieser grafik entnehmen können im
vergleich mit saudi arabien doppelt so
teuer
der größte teil des norwegischen öls
kommt aus der nordsee
und diese ölfelder teilt es sich mit
anderen ländern wie großbritannien
norwegen hat seinen ölreichtum jedoch am
besten verwertet okay jetzt denkt ihr
vielleicht wieder ein weiteres visual
politik video in dem mark uns bereit
erklärt wie norwegen durch die
privatisierung von unternehmen reich
geworden ist also diesmal ist die
geschichte anders
norwegen ist ein gutes beispiel dafür
wie staatskapitalismus funktionieren
kann was ist staatskapitalismus warum
ist norwegen so war mächtig was bedeutet
es für eine regierung an der börse zu
investieren heute werden wir alle diese
fragen beantworten aber bevor wir das
tun werden sie immer erst einen blick
zurück in die geschichte
[Musik]
die holländische krankheit wir müssen
ehrlich sein
norwegen war noch nie ein armes land
aber es war auch nicht immer besonders
wohl haben in den 1950 er jahren zum
beispiel genossen die norwegen einen
ähnlichen lebensstandard wie die
franzosen das bedeutet sie waren reicher
als die spanier aber ärmer als ihrer
städtischen nachbarn und natürlich die
amerikaner damals hatte niemand erwartet
dass man vor norwegen erdölvorkommen in
die google aber im jahr 1959 änderten
sich die dinge in diesem moment begann
shell mit der erkundung der noch hell
ist ein niederländisch britische
ölkonzern und suchte nach potenziellen
ölfeldern vor ihrer haustür in der
nordsee
[Musik]
eines tages gewannen sie einige kleine
gasquellen und wo immer ist da es gibt
gibt es auch rd also setzten sie ihre
erkundungs tätigkeit fort und so wurde
eines der größten ölfelder entdeckt ein
ölfeld guter britischen und norwegischen
gewässern in den 1960 er jahren erhielt
shell in diesen beiden ländern wo
letztendlich jahre später 1972 gründete
in die norwegische regierung eine eigene
gesellschaft statt all for you marry the
new start so bekannt der ölboom in der
nordsee in den siebziger jahren floss
das geld in strömen nach norwegen in nur
drei jahren konnten die norweger ihr
programm otto inlandsprodukt verdoppelt
und plötzlich bedeutet ein doch
technische traum in der ölindustrie zu
arbeiten werde schon nach lachs fischen
wenn man mit öl viel mehr geld verdienen
kann
das klingt wirklich fantastisch oder
[Musik]
nun eigentlich nicht tatsächlich hat
dieses phänomen einen eigenen namen
die holländische krankheit oder der
fluch des rohstoffreichtums
grundsätzlich gilt jedes mal wenn ein
land öl findet dreht seine wirtschaft
durch die regierung kann plötzlich wie
verrückt geld zum fenster hinauswerfen
und gleichzeitig die steuern senken
alle bürger wohl in der ölindustrie
arbeiten weil sie die lukrativste ist
was passiert dann
in nur wenigen jahren ist die gesamte
volkswirtschaft nur noch auf eine
einzige sache ausgerichtet die
produktion von dinosaur sobald man so
stark von nur einen einzigen produkt
abhängt bringt eine kleine veränderung
des marktpreises dieses produkts das
ganze land an den rand des bankrotts
genau das ist es wieder passiert und das
könnte auch anderen ländern wie saudi
arabien oder bachrain passieren so und
nun kommt der grosse unterschied
zwischen norwegen und großbritannien in
beiden ländern reagierten damals
linksgerichtete parteien aber deren
politik hätte nicht unterschiedlicher
sein können
im jahr 1976 befand sich großbritannien
mitten in einer seiner schwersten
finanzkrisen sollte die regierung ist
kaum erwarten sich auf die ganzen
einnahmen aus der ölförderung zu stürzen
und die ölquellen so sehr es nur ging
auszuquetschen norwegen hatte jedoch
eine stabilere situation und konnte erst
mal abwarten was bedeutet das nun
zunächst begann die regierung damit die
erdölbranche streng zu regulieren
außerdem mussten sich 50 prozent dieser
bohrinseln im besitz der staatlichen
firma stoll befinden
tatsächlich mussten ausländischen
unternehmen eine 78 prozentige steuer
auf ihre profile zahlen und das auch
noch nicht alles norwegen limitierte die
ölförderung streng sie dir nochmal
dieses diagramm an ihr könnt ihr sehen
wie das vereinigte königreich richtung
beginn der ölförderung voll aufs gas
drückte ende der 70er jahre produzierte
die briten bereits mehr als anderthalb
millionen barrel pro tag während
norwegen gerade mal erst ein drittel
davon fördert in den 80er jahren als
margaret thatcher großbritannien
reagierte förderte es weiterhin öl als
gäbe es kein morgen während norwegen das
alles immer noch recht entspannt angehen
was haben sie damit erreicht norwegen
gelang es mit der öl und gasindustrie
als rückgrat eine stabile und dynamische
wirtschaft zu formen aber machte einen
moment denn es gibt noch einen weiteren
unterschied
in den 1980 er jahren privatisierte die
premierministerin großbritanniens
fetscher die staatliche ölgesellschaft
british petrol die norwegische regierung
dagegen hat die kontrolle über stadt
voll behalten
auch heute noch hält der norwegische
staat 67 prozent der anteile
obwohl das unternehmen von statoil in
ecuador umbenannt wurde und ich weiß was
du denkst
mein gott norwegen sowas wollen
sozialistisch aber warte einen moment
tatsächlich das norwegische rechtssystem
ist den china ist ähnlich experten
sprechen von statt kapitalismus was
bedeutet dass der staat einen großen
teil der wirtschaft kontrolliert aber
nicht gleichzeitig wie ein großes
privatunternehmen verhält was bedeutet
das also nun schauen wir mal dass an
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der hedge-fonds start bevor wir
weitermachen erlaubt mir eine kleine
anmerkung denn die romantische und süße
melodie die ihr gerade hören könnte es
dem musikfest einer black metal bands
die ok nicht aus norwegen kommt sondern
aus kolumbien aber so klingt wie eine
typische norwegische band und sie hat
uns ihre musik für dieses video zur
verfügung gestellt wenn du mehr
verdienen können möchtest haben wir in
der beschreibung einen link zu ihrem
kanal nun zurück zu unserer geschichte
erinnerst du dich an die beiden bilder
die ich dir am anfang des videos gezeigt
habe und andere länder wie saudi arabien
gehen mit ihren gewaltigen öl- profiten
um wie ein drogenabhängiger rapper an
einem freitagabend die verschiedenen
norwegischen regierungen aber sowohl die
links- als auch die rechtsgerichteten
kamen jedoch jeden cent den sie ausgehen
wollten
100 mal umgedreht dazu führte dass nun
der ganze ölreichtum landete in der
sparbüchse spüren wir vor ins jahr 1990
in diesem jahr merkt das norwegische
parlament drei dinge erstens norwegen
hat eine mail ersparnisse zweitens der
ölpreis steigt und sinkt ohne dass
norwegen dies sonderlich beeinflussen
können und drittens das beste was sie
tun können ist ihre wirtschaft zu
diversifizieren und wie haben sie das
geschafft nun die lehre es mit an der
börse investieren
gesagt getan auf diese weise entstand
der staatliche pension spor norwegen ist
auch bekannt als der prüfung dabei
handelt es sich um einen von der
norwegische zentralbank kontrollierten
hedgefonds und ja ich weiß was viele von
euch jetzt denken was ist daran so
beeindruckend es gibt viele andere
länder mit einem staatsfonds china
australien die vereinten arabischen
emirate klar aber dieser hier ist der
größte von allen
wir sprechen von mehr als eine billion
us dollar das bedeutet wenn wir diesen
vor durch die gesamte
britische bevölkerung teilen hat jeder
bürger mehr als 200.000 us dollar in
aktien investiert aber das ist noch
nicht alles per gesetz wurde es
untersagt dieses geld für öffentliche
ausgaben zu verwenden das bedeutet dass
die regierung nur die profite des fonds
lösen kann nicht aber das kapital selbst
und glauben wir reden hier nicht über
ein kleines trinkgeld
wie norwegens stars wo in einem jahr 130
milliarden dollar verdiente ebenso
verbieten es den elegischen gesetz und
das geld in die norwegische wirtschaft
selbst zu investieren ausschließlich in
ausländische unternehmen aus diesem
grund ist norwegen heute im plus von 15
prozent aller weltweit existierenden
aktien natürlich luft ist einige jahre
besser als in anderen und nach ansicht
vieler analysten ist das management des
fonds zu konservativ und verdient nicht
so viel geld wie es möglich wäre
allerdings nutzt norwegen sein kapital
nicht nur zur diversifizierung der öl
vorstellt auch eine politische waffe da
norwegens ölfonds im wert von 105
milliarden dollar lässt seine aktionärs
muskelspielen der weltgrößte staatsfonds
legte im vergangenen jahr bei 6.700
unternehmensentscheidungen widerspruch
ein
so veröffentlicht die norwegische
zentralbank geht es ja eine schwarze
liste mit unternehmen in die sie aus
ethischen gründen nicht investieren
möchte dazu gehörenden hersteller
tabakproduzenten und unternehmen die an
korruptionsskandalen beteiligt aber das
ist erst der anfang denn mit wenn man
aktien einer börsennotierten
gesellschaft ist hat man das recht an
deren hauptversammlungen teilzunehmen
man kann den vorstand wählen über
wichtige konzerne entscheidungen
abstimmen und sogar themen zur
diskussion stellen und jene aktien du
hast desto wichtiger ist eine rolle bei
diesen abstimmungen die ein beispiel im
sommer 2008 10 führte facebook einen
neuen filter algorithmus für steak news
ein und beschloss maßnahmen zur
verringerung der gehaltsunterschiede
zwischen frauen und männer
diese beiden entscheidungen sind das
ergebnis von abstimmungen auf einer
hauptversammlung und rate mal wer diese
themen auf die tagesordnung gesetzt hat
natürlich war das neue und das gleiche
gilt für viele andere unternehmen
[Musik]
von wegen zweier unterstützt die
anliegen von aktivisten auf der alltag
mit hauptversammlung mehr sicher west
gehören zum alphabet konzern google und
youtube eine kleine gruppe von
aktionären wollte dass google den weg
news filter verfeinert mit der
unterstützung des norwegischen
staatsfonds gelang es ihnen hierfür
wichtige stimmen zu gewinnen das gleiche
geschah bei apple auch dort ist norwegen
einer der größten aktionäre und sie
halten sich in den hauptversammlungen
nicht gerade bedeckt im allgemeinen
dringen norwegen die größten unternehmen
der welt ihre unternehmenspolitik an
vier verschiedenen fronten zu ändern und
dabei geht es nicht nur um die
gleichberechtigung zwischen den
geschlechtern ein teil der norwegischen
ideologie befasst sich zum beispiel mit
diesem team
[Musik]
norwegens staat wird sich auf hohe
managergehälter einschießen ja in vieler
hinsicht verdienen die großen
multinationalen führungskräfte hohe
gehälter
obwohl ihre unternehmen geld verlieren
das haben wir in der finanzkrise
mehrmals erlebt wie ihr euch vorstellen
könnte die aktionäre diese unternehmen
damit nicht gerade zufrieden aber es ist
schwer etwas zu sagen wenn man nur einen
kleinen teil des unternehmens hält hier
kommt norwegen als anwalt der
kleinanleger endspiel was ist aber
wirklich in sich hat ist das jüngste die
biologische betätigungsfeld auf dem
norwegen mit seinen ölmilliarden die
muskeln spielen lässt
[Musik]
norwegen staatsballett entschieden gegen
emissionen vor
der norwegische staatsfonds hat fünf
unternehmen darunter den rohstoffhändler
glencore aus seinem portfolio
ausgeschlossen nachdem er eine harte
grenze für kohle emissionen festgelegt
hat der 1 billionen dollar schwere fonds
hat in dieser woche auch für ölfirmen
ding inakzeptabler emissionen
ausgeschlossen und damit alle nachzügler
in sektoren wie zement und stahl
wachgerüttelt
[Musik]
ja ihr habt vollkommen richtig gehört
mit den milliarden und abermilliarden
die norwegen mit dem verkauf von
klimaschädlichen erdöl verdient hart
bestraft ist nun andere die jetzt
eigentlich nur das gleiche tun wollen
viele länder versuchen die welt mit
hilfe des militärs zu beherrschen
anderer länder versuchen ausländischen
regierungen durch diplomatie zu belassen
norwegen versucht seinen einfluss auf
die größten globalen konzerne
auszuweiten das ist die norwegische
verschwunden
[Musik]
in der zwischenzeit können norwegische
bürger des nachts ruhig schlafen weil
sie wissen dass selbst wenn der ölpreis
sinkt ihre zukunft gesichert ist und
jetzt seid ihr an der reihe
glaubt ihr dass es eine gute idee ist
ein ganzes land an der börse investiert
findest du den norwegischen einfluss auf
den globalen kapitalismus gut oder
schlecht und ausreichend grund bitte
hinterlasst eure wertvollen beiträge im
kommentarbereich unter diesem video und
vergiss nicht dass wir jede woche brand
wohl videos veröffentlichen also ab und
zu diesen kanal klick auch auf das
glöckchen damit du keine beiträge
verfasst welche dieses video etwas
gebracht hat
die puls bitte einen leid daumen und
emma bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]